cyrille eldin cyril tu es allé avec
stella au medef alors c'est quoi le
medef ben le medef c'est une association
de patron qui fait pas une université
d'été fin août début septembre
et ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
c'était là veut faire de la politique je
voulais que cela produise dans le milieu
voilà quelques patrons quelques be nice
et regardez la réaction des ministres
des patrons quand cyril arrivé c'était
là c'est parti
alors tu vois la politique c'était là
c'est avant tout le terrain et là ô
démarre avec les journées d'université
du medef alors le nez des c'est une
association de gros patrons qui se
retrouvent entre les vacances et la
rentrée pour se rassurer des politiques
viennent les rassurer se rassurer eux
mêmes tout monde se rassure battant est
ce qu aurait dégelé jeunes non justement
tu vois où ils sont tenues à l'extérieur
là c'est comme un saut de riches
je vous présente ce qu'elle aimerait
faire de la politique elle voudrait
faire un parti qui s'appelle l'amour
plus fort que la gauche est ce que vous
pourriez lui donner un concert tu veux
pas reprendre ta retraite jouent la
présente stella quand même monsieur le
ministre
c'est son premier je vous présente
stella qui veut se lancer dans la
politique
et aimerait rejoindre quelle partie
parce que là on a le parti au
gouvernement
voilà enduite assure marche j'aimerais
bien faire plusieurs choses en même
temps ça marche je sois vous laisser mon
portable vous pouvez
simplement dit qu'il fallait c'est du
couchant grand débat on a fait un débat
avec des plateformes sur internet vous
présentons des plateformes sur des
petites absences sur internet où il y
avait plein de jeunes qui me posaient
des questions et moi des jeunes de 18 à
25 ans mais 10 minutes manière était
devenu un politicien n'est pas devenu un
politicien
tu vois je tiens la tension c'est très
bon pour tancer tueur électorat je vais
présenter stella qui veut se lancer dans
la politique
ils ont là tous les atouts pour le faire
rester là et ça port d'oran pour
mattmark sapin au dos rond pour smart
directeur de total et donc du coup je me
disais que je peux avoir un lot de
sapins andorran moi je ne font pas ça
mais enfin je suis con dire comme qui
est là pour tout vous donner je vous
présente ce thème qui veut apolitique je
te présente le seul homme de droite qui
a encore de l'avenir qui est crédible
qui est sur le terrain
alors ce film et ça ça va vous
compromettre monsieur savard du tout
c'est très assumé à mal
il tire les poêler les tissus les plus
vicieux que toi c'est patrick vient est
ce que vous pourriez lui donner un
conseil pour se lancer dans la politique
à stella fait
fellous il faut dire les voiles n'en
faut se re interview sur la grand moment
avant de se lancer dans la politique
c'était là va faire dédicacer son livre
enfin colas sarkozy
j'ai simplement demandé de m'écrire tous
les conseils qui pourraient me donner
pour devenir politicienne et du coup bah
je me retrouve un peu con parce qu'y a
juste écrit bien cordialement
et bah c'est peut-être l'essentiel à
comprendre en politique il faut savoir
dire bien cordialement après tu peux
faire toutes les crasses que tu veux
mais je dis bien cordialement
notre salut désir cette petite sortie au
medef
ouais on s'est vraiment bien amusés à
vraiment vous aviez déjà rencontré
nicolas sarkozy
non c'est la première fois je pense que
tel aviv pourquoi la dérive où il ya
sympa crochet en trouve mais il m'a
juste écrit bien cordialement alors que
j'ai posé un tas de questions
on attend la semaine prochaine ce qui va
se passer avec vous deux en tout cas
merci à cyril et leurs personnages
préférés
[Applaudissements]